Samantha's in Texas hi Samantha welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show oh hi Dave so
nice to meet you you too how can Anthony
not help well the problem that I'm
really having is only have nine cards in
collections and my student loan
everything else I mean baby step two so
everything else that I had like other
credit cards that were current and
medical bills and other things I already
have paid eight thousand four hundred
twenty four dollars out of it but now
I'm in between the student known that
he's forty five thousand and my
collection there are seventeen thousand
five hundred the reason I'm asking about
the connections which I know maybe you
will tell me to pay the student loan
first however I've been trying to move
out of my apartment because my rent is
really high but I apply for two
different apartments and due to my
collections or my credit they don't
approve so I'm stuck for another year my
friend men pay $1,300 no you're not you
just hadn't found a place to move yet
yeah other people work with if what you
would do is just tell the landlord
upfront rather than just blindly filling
out an application I've got some stuff
in collections but I'm working as Dave
Ramsey plan to get out of that and so
moving here is going to help me do that
and your rental easily be paid and you
just explained it only two places you
can't rule it out after two places to
places don't that you got a you may have
to talk to ten yeah but every time I
like they have to they tell me you have
to apply and and fill out an application
of cost like five hundred and sixty
dollars to two hundred hundred dollars
to fill out an application to get an
apartment I did two applications for
five hundred why not well each one of
them was probably 250
and the other one was you don't pay
somebody 500 bucks to apply to get an
apartment
no you fill out the paperwork yeah the
most the most the most with Department
Samantha the most you should be paying
us maybe 10 15 to 20 bucks for someone
they can do a credit application thing
on you that's the most but you're not
doing that Samantha listen today ven
listen to myself
you gotta get out there and do the
research I've personally called around
about 20 different apartment complexes
right here in the city of Nashville some
said yes and then some said no but the
majority of them that a call did say yes
so get out there and call now when it
comes to paying off your debt you know
you line up all your debt you know from
smallest to largest Dave is not going to
tell you to pay off your student loans
and skip over two other bills he's gonna
tell you to do the debt snowball I'm
gonna tell you the debt snowball and
that's what you got to work in in the
process right now you know the the
amount that's in collections if it's
several months behind you can just Park
it over to the side and come back and do
it after you get your debt snowball done
that's 17,500 right but but you do need
to move and you got to put little bit
more effort into it and you would never
pay 250 to 500 dollars to apply to fill
out an application to get an apartment
that's that's crazy land no no no don't
do that under any circumstances